les Russes sont en guerre pas contre
l'Ukraine contre le Troisième Reich
allemand nous sommes fin 1942 début 1943
et cette bataille la bataille de
Stalingrad va marquer les esprits et
faire basculer la future victoire des
Alliés Jean-Jacques Annaud le grand
réalisateur de La Guerre du Feu est plus
récemment de Notre-Dame brûle va
réaliser un film de guerre de prestige
deux grands acteurs d'un côté Jude Law
de l'autre côté l'Américain Ed Harris
ces deux hommes vont s'opposer sur le
champ de bataille ce sont tous les deux
des snipers
l'autre allemand la guerre est profonde
et chacun va être le plus rusé possible
pour abattre l'adversaire
Stalingrad réalisé en 2001 est un film
de guerre remarquablement reconstitué
connaît l'esprit technicien et très
méditilleux de Jean-Jacques Annaud et
lorsqu'il a voulu reconstituer il s'est
donné les moyens il n'avait qu'un seul
regret je crois quand j'ai regardé le
bonus du DVD c'est l'authenticité un peu
suspecte de l'un des chars du film tout
le reste est parfaitement
reconstitué au final les deux
personnages qui sont extrêmement malins
l'un et l'autre pour essayer d'abattre
leur adversaire vont se livrer un combat
épique qui va nous tenir en haleine
pendant plus de deux heures et l'on ne
voit jamais le temps passé c'est un film
captivant plus fort à mon avis pour
représenter les snipers que le film
américain sniper de Clint Eastwood film
de guerre film de thriller à suspens
vous ne vous embêterez pas une seconde
bon voyage